c'est bien connu du milieu industriel
les grands utilisateurs d'eau dépensent
des montants dérisoires au Québec pour
prélever des gros volumes ils ont payé 3
millions de dollars seulement en 2021
pour plus de 800 milliards de litres
d'eau une réputation un peu bonnasse
dans le gouvernement veut se défaire on
l'a donné notre eau essentiellement et
là on contribue à ce que le taux soit
plus soit plus conséquent le ministre de
l'Environnement veut multiplier par 10
les revenus de la redevance sur l'eau
les faire passer de 3 millions de
dollars par année à 30 millions les
usines de pâtes et papier par exemple ne
paieront plus seulement 2 dollars 50
mais plutôt 35 dollars pour le million
de litres d'eau les entreprises en
transformation comme les cimenteries ou
les fromageries verront la redevance
passée de 70 à 150 dollars quant aux
embouteilleurs les petites bouteilles
d'eau qui sont vendus au Québec et qui
ne contiennent que de l'eau provenant
des réseaux d'acqueuses pour moi c'est
un non sens ce type d'embouteillage qui
l'eau du robinet pratiquement devra non
seulement payer jusqu'à 500 dollars le
million de litres d'eau mais sa
bouteille à usage unique sera dorénavant
interdite enfin disent les groupes
environnementaux la réglementation
actuellement en vigueur datée d'environ
une dizaine d'années n'avait jamais été
mise à jour c'est un très bon pas que
l'on reconnaît puis on a de travailler
me fait plaisir de déposer le projet de
loi numéro 20 tous les partis
attendaient impatiemment le projet de
loi qui prévoit que l'argent servira au
fond bleu pour protéger les lacs et les
rivières nos lacs nous reviennent notre
fleuve manque d'amour une promesse
électorale de 650 millions de dollars
qui sera financé à hauteur de 500
millions finalement
espérons que le fond bleu soit pas trop
bleu parle nous attendons toujours une
garantie que le secret sur l'eau sera
complètement levé le secret de l'eau
parce que les environnementsalistes
espèrent que Québec s'assurera de la
transparence des entreprises pour
qu'elles déclare honnêtement les volumes
d'eau préle vés ici Véronique prince
Radio-Canada Québec